when a peltro is engaged to Brad Falchuk
after three years of dating
[Music]
the Oscar winner has been spotted
rocking a ring on that finger most
recently on Monday at a goop event in
Venice California now a source tells ET
that the 45 year old and her writer
boyfriend are engaged quote they've
actually been engaged for a year and
kept it a secret she's had the ring a
long time both Gweneth and brad have
been married before the GUP founder and
her ex Coldplay frontman Chris Martin
consciously uncoupled in 2014 but have
remained on good terms she opened up to
ET in 2016
about co-parenting their two children
Apple and Moses if you once loved the
person enough to have children with them
you'd have to focus on what you still
love about them and what's beautiful
about them and all the good aspects of
your relationship and hold that you know
in a number of years you still want a
family you're just not in a couple so I
acknowledge that we've done it in kind
of an unorthodox way but it's working
for us
[Music]
you